Cris ( TV )
Tiens, je me disais, tu ne m'as jamais parlée de tes ex !
De, de quoi ?
'fin, y a rien de particulier
je suis resté un an avec une fille mais bon c'est tout après...
et ... heu tu penses encore à elle ?
Non.
Non mais t'es un gros mytho quand même
parce que tu penses à moi tout le temps
parce que je te manque de ouf
J't'manque et en plus j'chuis mieux qu'elle
Hein! hein! t'étais mieux quand même chez moi
Hein je te manque ?
T'aimerais bien me remplacer mais t'y arrives pas
Elle bien nulle à chier ta vie hein sans moi
JE LA BAISE TOUT LE TEMPS
Ouais ben là c'était nos vacances, en Tunisie
On était heureux parce qu'on arrêtait pas de BAISER
Vacances dans le Tarn on s'est bien fait chier
du coup on a baisé
Là je l'ai rebaisée
et regarde !
Régulièrement, je la baise
A vous !
Ouais ?
Arrête, arrête
Tu c'est ce que c'est trois ans
moi je suis resté trois ans avec elle, moi
trois ans tu sauras jamais ce que c'est trois ans
On a eu un cochon d'Inde on l'a appelé Dagobert
chut ! putain Dagobert
OK mec, t'es tout bourré, t'es ridicule là
rentre chez toi
Qu'est-ce que tu crois, bien sûr qu'il l'a baisée !